hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome classical game it's from the
36th european club cup and it's between
arianthari and daniel dubov uh it
features uh well many great moves as
often chess games do but one very
particular one and it's also
the the reason why i decided to show
this game another is since so many of
you guys are requesting dubose games uh
but the the actual reason is uh this one
move so let's check it out and see what
this game is about so tari with the
white pieces opens with e4 and this is
the match uh between uh alkaloid and
author spiel uh atari and the dubois are
playing a board two so e4 we have e5
knight to f3 knight to c6 and the bishop
to b5 the rule opus is on the board we
have a6 morpheus defense from dubo
bishop to a4 and now knight to f6 we
have castles by tari and bishop to c5
i'm going for the neo archangel's
variation uh we have c3 uh b5 chasing
the bishop back bishop to c2 and now the
immediate d5 duboff doesn't mess around
he wants to open up the center right
away and tari replies with the strongest
reply and the most often played one and
that is d4 so a lot of tension in the
center and you can go about this uh many
ways but the the most usual way is just
the captures on e4 so here we have
knight captures on e4 uh if you remember
in the saint louis rapid
this year um
nakamura defeated caruana with d
captures on e5 but okay here we have
knight captures on e5 knight captures an
e5 d captures on c5 now grabbing the
bishop
and now there are a couple of games that
reach this position but the most common
move here is just knight to d3 it makes
sense you have a very nice um uh setup
here if the bishop captures you will
have a pass pawn here on d3 so this is
what everyone plays uh mamidyarov uh
played it uh levon arunian played it but
the move i believe in top tier play
never yielded more than a draw so
instead of this knight to d3 duval
chooses a move that has been never been
played before and he plays bishop to b7
so of course it is now as of move 10
that we have a completely new game and
this is where uh things can go very
wrong for white so bishop to b7 i
believe uh is uh is a bluff it's it's a
very well researched bluff of course uh
from duba where if white continues in
the best possible way duba will of
course just have nice fighting chances
uh and nothing seriously could
will happen to him of course white will
have to spend a little bit more time
the thing is uh
white doesn't want to capture with the
queen because then rook captures and
then black has the rook on the open d
file and you're just helping black
develop but the truth is if you capture
it with the queen and then rook captures
bishop to f4 is very very annoying the
knight is hanging if the knight moves
the c7 pawn is hanging and there really
is no uh good move to uh just uh
solidify here if you play something like
this this is a very clunky position it's
uh
just very very weird white can play a4
and already black is uh without any any
good moves there's just nothing nothing
for black to
to be done here it's it's a really
really bad position for black so what
you would have to do if the queens get
traded off queen captures you would have
to capture with the king and now this is
a much different game uh than if rook
captures and bishop comes to f4 now but
bishop to f4 isn't really doing anything
since the king already defends the c7
pawn uh you can just uh move the knight
and if you just continue knights to d2
then black also just continues with
knights to d3 and so on so this is what
uh tidy kind of should have gone for but
after bishop to b7 it seems he trusted
the dubai uh and he played bishop to g5
and okay dubo says all right i tricked
you again let's try again uh
one more time so he plays h6 and again
uh queen captures is the way to go if
you play queen captures again king has
to capture because if rook captures
we're still gonna play bishop to f4 and
the same ideas apply here so instead
after h6 we have bishop captures on f6
by tari and now queen captures an f6 and
now this is a much different position
than if the queens get traded off the
board because now this is a beautiful
pawn the knight still can jump to d3
maybe even to f3 in some lines the
bishop is just a monster here
and how can white uh continue here queen
to e2 uh maybe a way to go after the
pawn right away but tariq chooses rook
to e1 still the the idea is the same we
want to eliminate this spawn but now
duboff plays rook to d8 attacks the
queen queen to e2 and now the position
is very delicate but there is one move
that gives duboff incredible advantage
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find this uh incredible idea while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on not doing
anything weird like knight to f3 or
knights to d3 i know you guys were
looking at those moves but uh one thing
you might have seen is that the king is
still in the center of the board so the
main move here uh to achieve a great
advantage for black is to just castle
this is what do have played so
congratulations to everyone who found
this
you are an excellent supporter of very
natural moves in complicated positions
uh so what do you do here well obviously
we want to capture this pawn but if we
do this let's say we play bishop
captures on e4 black can just recapture
queen captures and now knights the d3
just wins the game for black uh the rook
is hanging and also queen captures on f2
is now being threatened so we have to
defend this let's say we play rook to f1
now comes rook f to e8 and what do you
do with the queen queen f3 but now we
just trade captures captures we pick up
the b2 pawn and black's position is just
too dominant white really has no moves
here your rooks are disconnected there's
no good way to develop the knight you
can't go to d2 you can't go to c3 if you
play knights to a3 or something like
that then the rooks really come down the
board with rook to d1 rook to e2 and
it's just a complete mess of a position
uh yes the material is equal for the
moment but black white has four pawn
islands he has a double c pawn a double
def pawn and this will be uh you know
some very easy and pleasant work for for
black's rooks so that's what ha what's
happening if you capture the the pawn
here so we have knight to d2 by tari now
developing a little bit before
recapturing but now knight to d3 of
course we're not going to wait with this
uh we have bishop captures c e captures
on d3 attacking the queen and now queen
to e3 the f3 square is no longer
available the bishop covers that so
queen to e3 queen to e5 offering a queen
trade right away uh is of course a
possibility but black would of course
decline this with queen to c6 and going
for checkmate so queen to e3 here by
tari and now rook f2 e8 by double and
now you really don't have a good move
for the queen uh if you play something
like queen to g3 to always keep an eye
on the g2 square uh it doesn't really
matter rook to e2 we just go after the
knight uh if you capture here then we
have this beautiful pass pawn on e2 we
open up our d file for the rook and this
is just winning for black and if you
play rotate the d1 you try and defend
the knight then just queen to e7
uh threatening rook captures on e1 and
if rook f1 then just let's say rook to
e6 and now there's uh well white is just
struggling so much at some point there
will be no more moves for white rook the
g6 is coming uh the g2 pawn will be
attacked queen captures on c5 is coming
just winning upon and black will always
be left with this beautiful past d3 pawn
so dari says all right i'm not playing
that game let's just give up the queen
for two rooks and see what happens so
captures captures and captures with
check king to h7 and now rook back to e3
keeping an eye on the d3 pawn but also
always having the option of going rook
to g3 if the queen threatens checkmate
so here we have queen to g5 preventing
this now if rook to g3 we just pick up
the knight here so instead we have
knight to f3 g3 is also an option but
you you kind of don't want to play this
opening up even more uh
your king king's position because then
you you might really get checkmated uh
so instead we have knight to f3
attacking the queen but here dubo just
trades we have captures captures and now
queen to d2 now yes it's two rooks
against the queen but the this queen has
now infiltrated white's position and
it's going to be very very difficult to
defend uh pretty much anything here uh
you could play something like rook to b1
to trying to defend this pawn just queen
c2 we kick the rook away then we pick up
this pawn this pawn this pawn and we win
a very nice game or we just push d2 and
we don't even have to pick up the pawns
so instead after queen to d2 we have
rook captures on f7 tyree starts going
after some pawns and now c6 defending
the c7 pawn you don't want to give white
a pass pawn just uh too too early rook
to d7 and now a5 dubo is postponing uh
capturing the pawn here or even uh
just a queen to c2 he wants to keep this
uh rook on a1 for as long as possible so
here we have h4 a4 by dubois and now h5
so grabbing more space here if you can
somehow get this rook into the attack at
some point you might get at least a draw
and now like i said queen captures on b2
of course possible at any time but then
uh
you really want to keep this rook here
for as long as possible so here queen to
c2 first
and now comes rook to d6 thought he goes
after the c6 spawn now comes d2
and now we are threatening a lot of very
nasty ideas like queen to c1 with check
so rook to f1 so you don't have to
capture the queen but you still keep an
eye on the d1 uh square twice but now
queen captures on b2 uh we have rook
captures on c6 now tari also has a pass
pawn queen captures on a2 we rook to d6
now ready to push the pass pawn while
keeping an eye on the past d-pawn and
the queen to c2 now
uh we have c6 just queen captures on c3
so keeping an eye on that pawn rook to
d1 this pawn is now going to fall but
now a3 dubo has two more pass pawns that
he's ready to push
and now rook captures on d2 yeah if you
play something like rook the other rook
captures on d2 to kind of keep an eye on
your pawn black just starts pushing and
you can never push your pawn because
well first you have to defend this
square so uh tyler tries it um with with
the sixth ranked rook we have rook six
captures on d2 and now queen captures in
c6 we have rook to d6 attacking the
queen queen to c2 now we have a
repetition here rook attacks the queen
queen to a for now and of course uh dubo
is ready to start pushing his past pawns
rook to a1 b4 and now rook d to a2 not
allowing b3 because then we capture the
a3 pawn so king the g8 now it's time to
start bringing the king into the game
g3 king to f7 we have king to h2 and the
now king to f6 we have f4
and now queen to d7 and now what do you
play here with white well you kind of
have to keep the rooks here if you don't
want to allow b3
but then again keeping the rooks there
isn't going to help you all that much
so here we have rook to e2
but now just uh queen to d6 so what do
you play here the eighth rebone will now
be protected when duboff pushes b3 so
kink the h3 if you just repeat rook e to
a2 it doesn't really matter queen d5 we
go after the h5 pawn and after g4 we
just play queen to d3 or queen to f3 we
attack these spawns there's really
nothing for for white to
do here we're going to pick up all of
those ones and then we're going to start
pushing these pawns as well so after
queen to d6 king the h3 but now just b3
now the pawns are unstoppable
rook to e3 going off after them and now
you could push b2 but that's gonna you
know require you to work for your meal a
little bit longer so here dubois just
placed a2 and he says the the b3 pawn is
off limits if you capture that just
queen to e6 check picks up the rook so
of course tary cannot play this uh he
played f5 now going for rook to e6 check
to win the queen uh but that has a
little effect as duboff plays b2 and it
was in this position on mu 44 that
arientari resigned the game and what a
great victory for daniel duboff uh you
could capture the queen here yes but
then just beat captures on a1 and then
black gets another queen into the game
and of course it's all over so really
really incredible game where uh other
than uh double using mind tricks here
there is no better explanation i think
for what happened in this position after
he played bishop to b7 so it's a it's a
new position of course uh tari has to be
aware that uh dubois
made the research and who knows what he
prepared for uh for for this game and of
course he uh thinks that dubo knows
every possible continuation after queen
capture 78 but it it seems that other
than this move there really are no are
no better moves and especially this just
allowing double with bishop to g5 bishop
captures queen captures to get so much
development in so rapidly this is like
uh he was feeding dupe of development so
really outstanding and uh yeah bishop to
b7 a move that only a player like duboff
could play in in such top tier
competitions i believe
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and not only did they win
this game but they also crushed the
other team these are the standings as
you can see they won uh alkaloid one
fifth uh five and a half to half where
where only magnus uh got a draw for his
team uh against mamadirov but even that
was an incredibly fighting game uh
maduro had some chances and he was
better for the most of the game but he
just dropped it at some point and uh it
was enough for magnus to get a draw but
it's it's very rarely that you will see
a 6-0 that almost never happens uh so
even here you know you see it was a five
five and a half to half uh but yeah uh
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
as so many of you were requesting a nice
dupe of game uh and how nice f for
duboff to to create one for us with such
a
incredible move like bishop to b7 uh i
would like to thank shanti chaganti
mathias vinta federico conte alfredo
zachary bell and mike pomerani for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank all for watching and i will see
you soon uh continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and uh
checking up on whatever else is
happening in the chess world uh so thank
y'all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day